In Israel, Israelis are voting in parliamentary elections...
...with Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu's decade-long hold on power at stake...
...as he faces a tough contest with former military chief Benny Gantz.
UN Secretary General Antonio Guterres is calling for all parties in Libya...
...to immediately engage in dialogue to reach a political resolution to the conflict there,...
...declaring "there is no military solution."
In Sudan, gunfire was heard outside the Sudanese military headquarters in Khartoum,...
...as anti-Bashir protesters took to the streets for a third day.
In India, police say state party lawmaker Bhima Mandavi,...
...his driver and three security personnel accompanying him, have been killed...
...after Maoist rebels attacked a convoy of India's ruling party with an improvised explosive device.
Finally from the US, President Donald Trump...
...says the United States will impose new tariffs...
...on more than 11 billion dollars' worth of exports from the European Union,...
...after the World Trade Organization ruled last year...
...the EU was illegally subsidizing aircraft maker Airbus.